David, do you think Washington, DC s strict
gun laws saved?
Lives during the Trump riot.
This is a very interesting question.
It's really a question that has to be thought
about in large numbers.
And what I mean by that is, statistically,
DC s gun laws almost certainly saved some
lives.
Let me talk talk through my sense of it.
And if you disagree with me, just let me know.
I know that the gun people often say gun laws
don't stop any crimes because the criminals
don't follow the laws anyway, the criminals
will find an illegal way to get a gun.
The criminals will bring guns where they aren't
allowed anyway.
So it doesn't make a difference.
And certainly anecdotally, that may well be
true to some degree.
That may well be true.
But there are certainly some insurrectionists
who opted to leave their firearms at home
who, if the laws were laxer in D.C., would
have brought guns with them.
Some of them certainly had guns with them.
We know that.
But the number of guns was certainly lower
because of Washington, DC s gun laws.
As a result of that, there are certainly some
people who, if they had had firearms with
them on that day in Washington, D.C., could
have been ending up in some kind of a confrontation
where either they would have taken outdrawn
or used their firearm or police may have used
one against them by virtue of seeing that
some of these individuals were armed.
So were there people in the Capitol with guns?
Probably.
Yeah, probably they were some.
Would the number have been higher?
Were the gun laws way more relaxed in Washington,
D.C.?
Yeah, I think it's undeniable that more people
would have had guns and reducing the number
of guns in the situation removes lowers the
probability that there would have been more
of an escalation.
Now, I know that there are lots of people
saying